Welcome to Module 10. A trained model is not a product. The jump from a notebook that hits 94 percent on a held-out set to a service that answers a thousand requests per second with predictable latency, version history, and rollback safety is where most machine learning projects actually die. This module covers the deployment stack end to end: packaging, optimization, serving, pipelines, and monitoring.
Start with the artifact. TensorFlow's SavedModel format captures the graph, the weights, the optimizer state, and — most importantly — named signatures. A signature is a typed entry point: an input spec, an output spec, and a callable. You can export multiple signatures from the same model — serve for realtime inference, score_batch for offline batch, get_embedding for retrieval. Signatures make the serving surface explicit and verifiable; without them you are shipping a pickle.
TensorFlow Serving is the reference production server. It loads SavedModels, exposes them over gRPC and REST, handles versioning automatically by watching a versioned directory structure, and supports batched inference for throughput. Batching parameters — max_batch_size, batch_timeout_micros, num_batch_threads — are the three knobs that trade latency for throughput. Tune them against your actual traffic, not against synthetic load; production traffic is bursty in ways benchmarks rarely capture.
For edge and mobile, the story changes. TensorFlow Lite converts a SavedModel to a FlatBuffer optimized for on-device inference. The runtime is small — around one megabyte — supports hardware delegates for GPU, NNAPI on Android, Core ML on iOS, and Edge TPU, and has a microcontroller variant that runs on a few kilobytes of RAM. The conversion is lossy in subtle ways: unsupported ops force fallback to CPU, and custom ops require explicit registration.
Quantization is the single highest-leverage optimization. Post-training dynamic-range quantization halves the model size and gives modest speedups on CPU. Post-training float16 quantization is the GPU-friendly version with near-zero accuracy loss. Full-integer int8 quantization is where the serious gains live — four times smaller, two to four times faster, and the only option for most microcontrollers — but it requires a representative dataset to calibrate activation ranges.
When post-training int8 drops accuracy more than you can absorb, move to quantization-aware training. QAT inserts fake-quant nodes during training so the model learns to be robust to the quantization it will see at inference. The final export is then a true int8 graph. Expect a small training-time overhead and a handful of tuning passes, but for classification and detection models the accuracy recovery versus post-training quant is typically one to three points — often the difference between shippable and not.
Pruning removes weights. Magnitude pruning masks the smallest weights to zero during training; structured pruning removes entire filters or attention heads so the speedup survives dense-kernel execution. Weight clustering maps all weights to a small codebook and stores the codebook plus an index per weight. Both techniques compose with quantization — prune first, then quantize — and together can deliver ten-times compression with single-digit accuracy loss on well-behaved models.
Graph optimization is the free lunch. Grappler rewrites the TensorFlow graph at load time: constant folding, common subexpression elimination, fusion of Conv-BN-Relu into a single op, layout optimization, and shape inference. XLA goes further by compiling subgraphs to optimized kernels for CPU, GPU, and TPU. For Transformer-heavy workloads, enabling jit_compile=True on the serving path can yield substantial speedups with no code changes beyond a decorator.
A model in production is half of the system; the pipeline that produces it is the other half. TFX — TensorFlow Extended — is the reference pipeline framework. Its components are canonical: ExampleGen for data, StatisticsGen and SchemaGen for validation, Transform for deterministic preprocessing, Trainer, Tuner, Evaluator, and Pusher. ML Metadata — MLMD — records every artifact and execution, so you can trace any production prediction back to the exact data and code that produced the model.
Preprocessing is the most common production bug source. If you transform features one way in training and another way in serving — even by a rounding error — predictions drift silently. The TFX answer is TFTransform, which builds preprocessing into a TensorFlow graph that gets bundled with the model. Training consumes the graph via tf.data, serving consumes the exact same graph, and the two can never diverge. This is called training-serving skew and it is the single biggest source of real-world model failures.
Once a model is live you need monitoring. Four signals belong on every dashboard: prediction latency percentiles — P50, P95, P99 — throughput in queries per second, error rate broken out by status code, and prediction distribution statistics by feature. The fourth is the subtle one: a model with ninety-nine-nine percent uptime and drifting feature distributions is silently failing in a way that standard SRE dashboards will miss. Tools like TensorFlow Data Validation run this comparison automatically against the training-time schema.
Drift has two flavors. Data drift is a change in the input distribution — a new device, a new season, a new customer segment. Concept drift is a change in the relationship between inputs and the target — last year's purchase patterns no longer predict next year's. Data drift can be detected from inputs alone; concept drift needs labels and therefore a feedback loop. Design the pipeline so labels flow back from production within a window that lets you detect regressions before they become outages.
Rollout strategies protect you from bad deploys. Canary rollouts route a small percentage of traffic — one or five percent — to the new model and compare metrics against the incumbent. Shadow deployments send all traffic to both and compare predictions offline without serving the new model's output to users. A/B tests split traffic by user cohort and measure downstream business outcomes, not just model metrics. Pick the pattern that matches your tolerance for user-visible regression.
Versioning is non-negotiable. Every deployed model needs a version pinned to a git commit, a dataset snapshot, and a set of hyperparameters. The deployment system should allow rollback to any previous version with one command. Model registries — MLflow, Vertex AI Model Registry, SageMaker Model Registry, or the open TFX MLMD store — give you this with approval workflows, stage tags like Staging and Production, and audit trails. Treat your model registry like you treat git.
Edge deployment adds constraints most cloud engineers never see. Battery budget caps inference frequency; thermal throttling degrades latency under sustained load; unreliable networks force on-device inference with asynchronous sync; privacy regulations often mandate it. The deployment patterns are specific: ship the model inside the app bundle or pull it from a signed CDN, version it independently of the app binary, and instrument enough on-device metrics to detect field regressions without leaking user data.
Common pitfalls in this module's labs. First, skipping the representative dataset on int8 quantization — calibration with sixteen random images gives garbage activation ranges. Second, benchmarking latency without warm-up — the first few predictions include graph-build and kernel-compile overhead and are not representative. Third, ignoring tail latency — P50 looks fine while P99 is timing out one user in a hundred. Fourth, assuming your validation accuracy survives quantization — always re-evaluate the post-quant model on the validation set.
That closes the course. You built a mental model of deep learning, trained CNNs for vision and RNNs and Transformers for language, generated images with GANs, forecasted sequences, and now deployed all of it. The arc from a one-line Keras Sequential to a monitored TFX pipeline is long, but every link in the chain is now in your hands. Go build something that survives contact with real traffic. That is the entire point.